[Music]
hey man you jackie chan fan i love
dragon ball yeah yeah like skill one to
ten how much you love
like his old movies like it's like the
old rumble of the bronx type movie yes
those ones how about right now i haven't
seen you know i post the foreigner
jackie chan yeah is there any movies
he's done after the foreigner
he's working all right one right now and
he's getting some heat for it rush hour
four
my favorite that sounds dope i've been
in pre-production for like years oh
really i feel like the idea of it came
yeah like they were gonna make it for a
long time but uh rush hour yeah because
chris tucker don't want to do movies no
more really
that's why he stopped doing it what is
he gonna do nft
rush hour three wow you gotta give him
like a stupid paycheck to do it who
wouldn't have done it what is he doing
now just overlanding silver lightning's
playbook too
i'm in i mean he just wants to retire i
don't know
something i don't know
like mace
jackie chan is currently producing a new
movie um but he's getting a little bit
heat from it because is it the tuxedo
too just know one of the scenes he had
just filmed was actually in a syrian
town that had been flattened by an assad
bombing
oh so fury among activists dude they
need to just get mad at the location
scout not him
people understand departments who's
gonna get mad at the location scout
though yeah wait they're mad this is a
recent bombing and they filmed there uh
enough so basically war scenes for a new
jackie chan uh film are being produced
um in a syrian city that had been
leveled by assad bombing according to
the activists the film is called home
operation does it look more realistic
you know
it's so expensive to get this whole
scene in hollywood what we need to do is
just go cheaper yeah
if it's already oh this is a perfect set
that's it's amazing it's it looks so
real scout is so twenty look at the
warships oh this is perfect that's
perfect yeah i guess that's in bad taste
i know right it looks so real
well let me i'll give you guys more
details and you can make the uh
assumption studios like to save money
but don't don't we already do that with
like american war films don't like when
you do civil worship they go to the real
sites for like because if you don't do
the real [ __ ] then they get mad at you
and they get mad yeah they're pissed
like why did you shoot that in vancouver
so so
the film home operation um which
explores the emergency evacuation of
chinese citizens from yemen during the
outbreak of war in 2015. oh was partly
filmed near the ruined regime held city
of alhajar al-aswad
south of the syrian capital damascus
so home operation is a chinese emirati
collaboration film according to the
country's ambassador to china uh and
activists are pretty much just outraged
over the movie because they're labeling
it like whitewashing of assad war crimes
and shameful behavior by the syrian
regime's allies china and the uae
okay well you know what people need to
realize it's a two-party thing if
they're shooting there somebody gave the
okay in that territory so you got them
to be mad at yeah
you can't buy what's not being sold hey
dude your logic that's very true but
also it probably looks really funny when
they're screen testing and they're like
go in front of that rubble and say i
don't want no trouble
it works
something
we love it we love it let's do it did
you say rubble or trouble like that shot
better than the one we shot in culver
city
there's a better feel to it yeah the
culprit city went i don't know
do you think they tried a couple of
shots and like in front of green screen
they're just like i'm just not feeling
this let's go to syria yeah yeah yeah
but it's a collab between china chinese
emirati yeah
or uae sorry united arab emirates right
yeah so they don't have access to
hollywood
and they don't have movie sets
well in china they do but it looks
nothing like the middle east
china movie such a crazy event yeah dude
i heard they have actual movie cities
they do we we filmed one in there one of
our videos
like they don't even build sets they
just build the actual city and then they
just leave it there empty after
there's a whole town in china or a whole
city that we flew to um that literally
dedicated to all just like crazy epic
movie sets so you could see it um i
think it was like a glitch mob um
take to whatever take me from here or
whatever um it's track that we did and
we're in in front of these like
they're like 300 foot tall like giant
siddhartha buddha like multi-hand like
goddesses and stuff there's like huge
[ __ ] you know laying down buddha
structures or like there's like roman
like temple wow
and they're not they're all for movies
only it's literally a movie production
city there's even giant buildings that
house only like war costumes so that
epic chinese films that have like
thousands of people can be filmed in
these like large cities
and you pay for a an admission to that
space like it's a [ __ ] disneyland you
pay for an admission and then you can
film whatever so that's what we did all
of us all of us we just paid this really
small fee because it costs a lot to get
there and get housed but once you're
actually there because it's a really
remote area you're only paying like x
amount they have no [ __ ] toilets and
plumbings all [ __ ] i was [ __ ] in the
worst [ __ ] toilet situation i've ever
been in my life you're in like the
palmdale of china
that might be worth it to get some sick
shots yeah it is dude i used to i
suppress houses in palm beach
oh [ __ ] i gotta go all the way to
palmdale yeah you're a hustler dude he
does everything this guy dude i just
like the idea of you like being a new
appraiser and just freestyling the price
just long ago i don't know 600 000
like how much you paid for it huh this
right here i'll just show quick like
snippets like that full-on desert
this right here whoa
buildings that people use as actual
buildings well is that a is that a
building right there
well that's crazy
these are all literally just it's a
giant movie set like amusement park
with all these different spots that just
look crazy that's so sick and we just
shot in front of all of them because it
was like a [ __ ] field day that's
[ __ ] dope this is a village in a town
again same thing nothing actually
happens in it but there are movie sets
that have like a tea house a horse
stable a blacksmith armory a [ __ ]
like basket [ __ ] weaving spot black
smith armory it's not that hard look at
this like why that's sick then it makes
it looks like it just make it look like
you just went to [ __ ] grease to just
shoot that scene epic ass what the [ __ ]
that looks like this is definitely my
favorite genuine commercial you did
show me your parts i don't want to see
the i wanted to see you dancing honestly
that's what i'm thinking i'm like the
scenery is dope but i want to see more
anthony it's nothing but mike's song
dude there's no anthony he's stealing
the show
they're turning it's me i want to see it
and i appreciate that you know
in china they got this one town that's
modeled after like a north dakota like
town in china yeah so it looks like old
america why [ __ ] weird is it 1880
town or something like that no it's just
like it's like they just for some reason
picked this specific town to like copy
exactly to do like american films
so good with all chinese people
but then people actually like live there
too
wow they're like it's a house it's
[ __ ] weird
because you know how they have like a
fake paris and like a fake yeah i heard
they have it all big statue of liberty
that everything really which is why i'm
like jackie why did you film in [ __ ]
china syria why'd you have to go to
regulators you have like an exact eiffel
tower like
like one to one and it's like but it's
in the weirdest spot like super desolate
no one lives there one to one scale like
same size it's exactly the same that's
[ __ ] bananas yeah they have like a
regular mount rushmore
but it's all like bondo
they have the pyramids of egypt in china
but nobody cares about i bet that's on
its way right now they're building it
right now i wish they busted a ocean's
11 and build the actual white house and
like hey you want to know what i'm gonna
do to you guys i'm gonna [ __ ] blow up
the white house in front of them and
send videos over and then and then when
they [ __ ] fbi
fbi are looking at what happened and
they see bellagio written on the fbi
white house floor oh my god
they put that title they stole the white
house it's just they just do demos with
threats
the chinese guys flipping around
what [ __ ] you bin
that's my favorite part his hands stuck
in here yeah yeah yeah they call him a
greaser yeah yeah
they already have a freaking chinese
elon musk yeah
that's true because there's like a
billion chinese people they're bound to
look like they're gonna have they're
gonna be a few words
or something 6 million 1.6 billion or
something i don't know hey do you think
jackie thought he was gonna get any and
like do you think him filming at this
place was controversial in his brain at
all no he don't want no trouble or the
production
like do you think in their mind they
thought they would get any pushback for
them i'm sure that there was like maybe
a yellow or orange flag that went up but
i bet you that in a judgment call it was
like superseded by like the pro of
trying to tell a story of like surviving
yeah because that's an important story
too i think you know what i mean they
probably had this like a larger national
sense of pride to like get this type of
story and exposure out versus like we're
really trying to uh be disrespectful to
this like you know 500 000 massacred
type of like location i don't think
jackie chan is going around going i
don't want to be cancelled
yeah because he's already getting [ __ ]
from actual uh like hong kong really
what are they going after because he's
too damn pro china now yeah well it's
because he was getting [ __ ] from china
and in that battle he picked who would
win in a fight so he said i'm gonna go
on that that's because his son got
caught smoking weed that's why
yeah his son got into some [ __ ] and then
and then china was like i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
if you don't [ __ ] turn it around he's
like i
i don't want no trouble
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]